foreign
try that
[Music]
[Music]
bones and all is about two kids in the
80s who are Outsiders falling in love I
smelled you I didn't know I could do
that my character is maybe self-stylized
as an outsider being his identity and
Tamara and it's new they're almost
trying to sniff out if their new partner
was safe I don't want to hurt anybody
famous last words she can sense that
there's something about him that she
connects to but she doesn't exactly know
how she did that or why once they start
speaking they know that they're made up
of the same stuff are there lots of us I
don't actually meet many others
foreign
you have a young woman who has to find
her own identity and the long and Dark
Quest she goes through deals with the
extremities of her identity
I think it's an on the road love movie
inspired by the way we carry now is the
younger generation it's so heartfelt so
romantic these are very misunderstood
people I think I'm most excited for
audience is to experience the story that
goes in whatever Direction it wants to
go based on the whims of Luca guadalino
I want people to love these characters I
want people to not judge them to feel
for them root for them okay I'm looking
for you I smelled you the marriage of
tenderness and intimacy and violence and
horror is very very classical you find
it in most good stories what did you do
I hit him right up and it felt great
I think this film is for the lovers for
everybody who feels like they're alone
in the world there is somebody else that
is like you
yeah I love the weirdos I don't think
I'm a bad person